hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
so if you want to think about bentham's
utilitarianism and we want to think
about
specific types of examples education is
a good area to dig into
why because you're always dealing with a
number of different people
that have to be helped or taken care of
who are at risk for for benefits or
harms and
you generally have limited resources too
don't you
you have to make decisions about what to
do with time
effort money and you have people who are
at different levels as well
so there's a lot of really interesting
questions that we can ask with respect
to education
let's start with just a classroom
thinking about
single class a single classroom
i have only certain capacities
you know a certain amount of time
certain amount of energy
who should i spend it on how should i
spend it on
my students should i give an equal
amount to everybody
should i give some students more
attention than others
how do we decide these sort of things if
you're a utilitarian
you look at what would produce the
greatest overall
balance of pleasures over pains so let's
say
i have generally you know we divide
students up into three
groups this is kind of a dirty little
secret about
educators there's like the you know the
brilliant students
who are going to do great no matter what
and you might foster them
there's the students who are going to
struggle and sometimes
it's because they're they're out of
their
their league where they are sometimes
it's because
they have bad preparation beforehand
it's a product of previous education
sometimes it's due to character issues
like not wanting to work
but for whatever reason there are
students who struggle right
and then there's the vast majority of
students who are you know more or less
on track but
they do require some some attention some
structure
and uh who do you teach to
i mean if your goal is to produce
geniuses you can say well
forget these other kids i'm going to
focus on these kids
because they're the ones who are
probably going to be the greatest
benefit to the community later on down
the line
and if each one of them let's have a
class of 20.
each one of them is going to benefit
thousands of people and improve their
lives
maybe it's not so bad if i if i let the
five bad students fall through the
cracks
let's say there's five really good
students and five really bad students
and then everybody in the middle
and the other kids in the middle they're
not going to get as good of an education
and they're not going to be as happy but
it's okay because i'm gonna benefit
thousands
what do you think from utilitarian
perspective is that
is that a good
way to allocate my my resources
yeah how do i know they're going to
benefit thousands this is where that
that
issue of probability comes in
there's lots of bright people
you guys know lots of bright people are
they all productive
do they all benefit society some of them
turn to evil
don't they don't they use their talents
for that
did you ever hand them out okay um
you know if the odds aren't that good
then maybe actually i should be
investing my
my time and effort into the the kids
that i actually have in the classroom
imagine those k-12 right um
maybe i should actually be spending my
resources on the struggling students
and giving very little attention to the
super bright students because they're
going to take care of themselves and the
bulk of my attention to
the students in the middle and then to
the students who are really struggling
maybe that would have the better payoff
wouldn't it
maybe we should have greater resources
for that
if you only could have remedial programs
or a gifted and talented program
you have to cut one of them which should
be key
it's a big question isn't it these are
the sort of things that school boards
have to face
teachers have to face parents have to
face and that affect a lot of people's
lives
you know so questions of should we
actually be carrying out
for example special education
or should we just mainstream these kids
would they be better off would they
generate would it would generate more
happiness
more pleasure over pain to put kids who
have special
really you know sometimes severe special
needs into classrooms with all the other
kids
think about all the different things
that would go into this what are some of
the the pains that might occur
what are some of the negative outcomes
that could happen
yeah the children with special needs
socially as well
yeah so it can lead to fights and
bullying and
you know tension yeah distracting
like classroom environment yeah it can
make it very difficult for the kids who
are you know not brilliant but are good
to pay attention to progress to get as
much out of their education i mean we
never have enough time for teaching
anyway
so if we're going to spend half an hour
explaining to little johnny over here
why it's not okay to you know
blurt things out in class that's taking
away class time from the rest of
the students isn't it any other negative
outcomes
you can think of maybe the kids actually
don't like it
or maybe they do there's a lot of times
you have to do empirical research if you
want to be utilized
are there any benefits to it
if you want these kids to be able to
integrate and socialize you better find
some way to do it
and that's one way to do it um so if you
if you don't do that then you're gonna
have some other negative tradeoffs
oftentimes too
with utilitarianism it's not necessarily
looking for the most pleasure
it's looking for what harms the least
and harms the least amount of people
how many how much resources should we
devote to special lab
that's a big question that would have to
be assessed
by those sort of needs um
what should the purpose let's ask a
bigger question
what should the purpose of education be
in general
should it be to equalize opportunity
across the community
should it be to provide a
good background that can be built upon
for vocational
or liberal arts or specialized training
should it be to keep people off the
streets i mean that's one positive
benefit of actually
having kids in school they stay out of
you know
abandoned factories and malls
and other places where they tend to get
in trouble you know that's the way some
administrators
actually look at it just they call it
warehousing get them off the streets and
in the schools from a utilitarian
perspective there is a benefit to that
it's not a very great benefit but it's
some benefit right
um when we're thinking about the
purposes of education
if one of the purposes is to like train
an educated citizenry that can
participate in
democratic decision making then we'd
have to ask ourselves
are we actually doing a good job in
promoting that there's a system that we
currently have which is kind of like a
patchwork
you know different states have their own
things and then each municipality has
its own thing
how well does that actually work out a
lot of inequalities right
property taxes are a big part of that
if you wanted to change that you could
make a utilitarian argument for that it
would be better for society as a whole
to have more
equality in education or you know
on the other hand and again it all
depends on how you assess the numbers
maybe it's better to have a system like
we currently do have where
you know if you want to go to a better
school move to a better school district
if you don't care about that sort of
thing if other things matter to you more
you don't you know it doesn't matter to
you what kind of school your kids are
going to
live wherever you want maybe maybe
that's the system to have from a
utilitarian perspective
let's think about how classes want to be
set up
how hard should classes be
if you make them too hard
they're less enjoyable right have any of
you ever been in classes that were too
easy for you
are those enjoyable yeah that is a
certain extent you get to screw around
but no why not
yeah you feel like you're wasting your
time
yeah um especially when you're paying
for it
too now right um how much
homework should i should i give students
i can look at that from the utilitarian
perspective what will actually produce
the greatest amount of benefit to my
students
there's you know too much that's going
to produce more pain
more negative outcomes than benefits
there's too little
students won't get that much out of it
then there's the
goldilocks region of the just right
isn't there
should i use a lot of active
learning
as they call it i'm gonna actually put
it in quotes because i'm gonna
make it versus something else
you know should i for example have like
divided you up into
pairs and you do utilitarian
calculations and then come up to the
board
each pair and explain the situation that
i gave you and then go through that
would that have been
greater benefit to you as students than
actually you know sort of more
traditional lecture format
if it would have been of greater benefit
to you then i should be doing that
on the other hand it's kind of
interesting when you do those sort of
active learning things
you've got to really know what you're
doing and have it prepared well or
students don't get much out of it
and tend not to like it and a lot of
students
actually say we need lectures my
professor
never lectures and i have no idea what
the hell is going on
because she you know he or she just
gives us exercises to do and i don't
know the basic concepts
this would be something that you could
evaluate on the basis of utility
utilitarian calculation um
one other thing to think about and then
we'll close there's a lot of discussion
right now about
common core standards and a curriculum
and assessment and you know having
evidence that schools are actually doing
doing a good job in educating children
um could you think about that from a
utilitarian perspective would it make
sense to say yes we ought to have some
sort of process like this in place
or would that have more negative
consequences as a result
that's tough to think about